so very good morning to you and I do
want to talk about Eurovision in just a
moment but um before we get on to that a
couple of stories around today that I
want to ask you about firstly comments
by the former conservative Home
Secretary Priti Patel today saying that
Rishi sunak needs to offer more hope and
optimism for conservatism or she says he
risks
presiding over a managed decline of the
party and defeat at the next election is
she right
so I you know I I have a marginal seat I
am reliant on the Grassroots of the
party to help me they are determined as
I am and I think most people within the
party to support the prime minister in
the Endeavors that he has to try and
grow the economy and tackle the issues
that are the people's priorities so I
think what they want us to do is to
unite to work together tackle those
issues and then go on to work towards
winning the next election
so comments like this from pretty Patel
are helpful then are they going to be
seen as sour grapes from a grieved Boris
Johnson supporters
look I'm not you know it's a privilege
for me to work with my colleagues I'm
not going to criticize them it's right
that we have discussion about the
direction of the party but I think what
is really crucial is that we focus on
those issues that the Prime Minister has
rightly identified because that's what
people tell us they want us to deal with
and that is what we will be focusing on
well yes and but some Tory members might
have some sympathy with her views
mightn't they they they may say we
didn't actually vote for for Rishi sunak
as leader and we've now just seen him
presiding over terrible local election
losses with a thousand seats gone
well there were difficult elections of
course they are and you know I know from
my own constituency that hard-working
counselors had a really difficult night
but they equally want us to focus on the
issues that matter to the people of this
country that is what we are doing that
is what we need to concentrate on and
then work towards the next election it's
great to have debate but let's also
focus and unite behind those key issues
so that we can work towards victory in
the next election
do you think he does he does it's a work
on a more conservative vision for the
country rather than just spending his
time trying to fix crises and problems
well look we've undoubtedly gone through
a very difficult time and it was right
that we were there to support people
through those cost of living issues and
but now he is focusing very rightly on
making sure that we are growing the
economy that's what people want they
want security they want to see better
standards of living and that is what we
are focusing on doing
is promising a vision he's talking about
a radical general election Vision he
says that the Tories are being
unconservative that they're failing to
understand people's need for stability
order and security and that might ring
true for some Tories mightn't it
well I'm afraid I've heard Kia Stormer
relaunch himself so many times that I've
lost count and uh when I speak to people
on the doorstep I have to say that he's
not particularly resonating with them he
can do whatever he likes the fact is
that we are concentrating on growing the
economy making sure that we cut
inflation a deal with the small boats
and make sure that the NHS waiting lists
are reduced so these are key priorities
of the people I speak to in my
constituency and it's right that we
focus on those and we will continue to
do so a quick thought on how you think
that's going so far the bank of England
this week has revised its projections
for inflation up by the end of the year
and also the the latest growth figures
yesterday showed that in March the
economy shrank by 0.3 so those those two
priorities that you highlight there
aren't going so well at the moment are
they
well because we you know we have gone
through an incredibly difficult period
there's no doubts about that we haven't
made the promise that this will be
sorted out overnight but we are on a
plan the budget that the chancellor
announced uh specifically looked at many
of those issues to help us to grow the
economy and those are the issues that we
are focusing on rightly so
and one other issue that I did want to
ask you about because there are a number
of of head teachers as well as
um parents who are concerned about it
and this is the SATs test and one paper
in the SATs test this is for year six
pupils who are 10 and 11 they say that
that was extremely hard I think one head
teacher is talking about at the test
including some GCSE level questions
what's your take on this was it too hard
so I mean my view is that I want all
children in this country to have the
very best education possible because it
is the foundation for their whole lives
and testing children and encouraging
their skills is an important element of
their education I think therefore you
know the the tests seem to me to be uh
fine and we need to you know continue to
do that there's a lot of work going on
in education to raise our standards so
that we have the best educated children
to compete in a very difficult global
economy
uh to turn our attention to Eurovision
you are in Liverpool of course and we've
seen um the Prime Minister and uh Boris
Johnson as well both expressed this
appointment the president zelensky isn't
going to be able to address the contest
tonight first of all do you agree with
them would you like to see an address
from him
well I think yeah I think it is
disappointing that he's not able to make
that address that is a decision for the
Ebu it is their contest but actually if
you come to Liverpool what you see
everywhere you go are great uh you know
contributions from from Ukraine from
Ukrainian artists you cannot escape the
fact that this although this contest is
being held here in Liverpool you cannot
escape the fact that people know that it
should be held in Ukraine and I've spent
time yesterday with the Ukrainian
Ambassador and the culture ministers
from Ukraine and they were frankly
overwhelmed by what they had seen
Liverpool have put on an amazing show
and really made sure that that Ukrainian
influence is felt in every element of
this festival and competition here
oh we understand that the mayor of
Liverpool Steve Rotherham has said that
he's going to also speak to the
Ukrainian Ambassador and the mayor of
leviv who I think are both there to
discuss what could be done about
providing some sort of platform form
president zelensky what have you heard
about that and what form could that
potentially take
so I was speaking to both the Ambassador
and the minister last night about
options my understanding is the
president is very very busy but he he
has already sends a message saying how
grateful he is to the United Kingdom and
to Liverpool for hosting this show on
their behalf and I think everybody here
now is just focused on ensuring that
this contest continues to be as
successful as it has been all week and
you know I can get a sense from the
people here now that they're just
wanting to get on with the party
I'm sure they are but there'll be no
there'll be no site of president
zielinski at all tonight is your take on
it yeah
that's my understanding that's a
decision the Ebu have made
um but you know despite that Liverpool
city council that combined Authority and
us and dcms have worked together to make
sure that there are lots of Ukrainian
things to see here lots of cultural
elements that have been installed for
people to look at and there will of
course be mentioned of the fact that we
are hosting this on behalf of Ukraine in
the contest this evening okay and very
briefly who's going to win
I will of course the United Kingdom but
I think also Scandinavian countries from
what I can see from the action of the
audience they're going to get a good
night too so who knows it's Eurovision
song contest anything can happen that's
so true Stuart Andrew thanks very much
indeed for your time we appreciate it